absolutely well we are all on the edge
of rc
tanya and it's very nice to see how uh
magnus sat down i mean
uh the point is is that it looks like
the back injury that
had impacted him so much in the sixth
set
isn't an issue he said sat down rather
gingerly and
uh i was dead wrong um
uh peter no karo khan
no karo khan but yeah magnus made sure
that he will not land in this structure
that uh
cost him those those defeats he played
the move d6 and after castles
there is a new twist of a6 uh basically
hunting down divides bishop at all costs
hikaru reacted with
bishop takes c6 b takes c6 d4 breaking
the center
black captured on d4 quindy for bishop
e7 e5 c5
on the board queen f4 also
on the board all played very quickly
uh for an opening that at least for
ourselves was very unexpected
uh how deep is their preparation that
they seem to be ready to
to play every type of position in
under the sun uh uh peter i i'm just
amazed that they just
and and look they have more time than
they started with oh sorry
i take that back hikaru has more time
than he started with
yeah exactly i mean but simply once
magnus showed this direction with d6
then i think team hikaru must have
anticipated that after castles
what happens after a6 because it was
about the smooth order issues
uh i don't know how deep was their
preparation but
at least definitely they have kind of
spoken about it that okay yeah a6 exists
the way how he could reacted
navigate got a very strange possession
because
opposite colored bishops if white
stabilizes
then one can argue that black has some
weaknesses
pawn c5 pawn c7 on the other hand black
is very active
so black will try to compensate for this
damage pawn structure by
active piece play exactly bishop b7
the moment you said active piece play i
saw the bishop coming on b7 i said yeah
that was
a that was a very necessary move and
peter we've seen some
uh in-game positions of bishops of
opposite color
where an extra pawn here or there has
actually
not been important uh even
for example a move like knight e4 here
is the ending nope we didn't see we saw
queen e6's these
are these endings where the c5 pawn is
is missing are they uh good enough there
is a trick by the way i see
queen c5 bishop g2 but uh peter
yeah well i mean uh of course if white
can just collect the pawn and
play an end game with pawn up and
opposite crawl bishop with with the
rooks on the board
that's that's a dream scenario for white
very good winning chances
on the other hand black doesn't have
anything about against giving up the
pawn if he can
exchange all the heavy pieces and can
just go down to uh
opposite colored bishop end game uh
however
magnus with queen e6 of course wants to
highlight that i want to have my counter
play i want to keep queens
right he goes queen c6 eyeing the
g7 pawn now of course bishop takes e5
would be a terrible blunder due to
rookie five all of a sudden winning a
piece and winning the game
cleverly plays the move f3 and
h6 queen takes c5 this is a clean pawn
yeah that was a very surprising move by
um for for me at least
by magnus i had expected the move
uh c5 c4 for sure because okay
as you say it's a clean pawn i i just
want you to go back
very very quickly because there was a a
movement that uh
hikaru played h3 and the reason why
hikaru played h3 if you take the move
back
and not queen takes c5 there was a
cheapo bishop takes g2
king takes g2 queen g4 check and that's
an instant draw
for black if not more so that was why
hikaru played h3
and sorry to say uh go back to the
current position peter
and what do we have yeah well we have
this what
we have actually discussed that if white
gets a
pawn for nothing with the rooks on the
board and these are
excellent winning chances i mean this is
a total nightmare scenario for black
of course practically you can finally
hold this
but especially in a blitz game white has
white has all the chances to to win this
right and we
have seen the extraordinary tenacity
of hikaru holding
difficult endgame positions
the shoe is on the other foot uh magnus
uh i i'm looking at the very end
position of game two in game four
uh both came to a stalemate one
stalemate there was a pawn on h7 for
magnus in the other game
there was a stalemate on a7 magnus has
been the one
who's been pushing and coming up
empty withdraws uh now he's got to
defend it and as you say peter
uh this for me is a nightmare
uh for the black player because white
has
all of the trumps and
really just nothing to worry about
yeah but thanks to this bishop on e6 and
with a very quick
e5e yeah this is very strategically very
very important that why
black fixes his pawn on a4 forces white
to place the otherwise
white would not be able to activate the
rook from a1
so the actually another structure
is still upon up but not so easy to
create any postpone
the bishop on e6 gives stability so now
it's maybe the time for white yeah get
the bishop to cc
start advancing g4 h for king g3 magnus
of course uses the chance to go bishop
f5
he wants to trade one pair of rooks does
he want to change
is that so good i think he does yes
and he has in fact um and i think
it's absolutely of vital
importance for hikaru's
chances to win this game to keep the
the rook on the board after a move like
rookie six check you never want to play
rookie two
but because there is a rook on the board
it does mean that
rook to d8 check and king d2 and
maybe rook a8 could be really really
a a way that you just find yourself in a
lost position
yeah exactly i mean if the that's why i
did not like the exchange of rooks uh
so easily because white gets successful
of bringing his king to d2
yeah g4 included of course this bishop
on f5 is very
powerful let's kick this bishop away
well the bishop on
f5 was tickling the pawn on c2 so
the immediate rook d8 to a8 would have
been met by bishop c2 so that's why
hikaru is trying to drive the bishop
away from the c2 pawn bishop g6
stubborn as ever
keeping an eye there uh check
and now after king f7 there will be
another check
and hikaru wants to put his king on d2
which he has done
yeah now the question is how to
how to protect these pawns how is it
possible to protect these pawns because
white is threatening to to attack them
and i think we also have to keep an eye
on the clock because the
in this endgame clock will play a very
vital role
absolutely uh rook b7 so there's some
ideas that if you go after
the c pawn with rook c8 or even the apon
with uh rook a8 you've got to check but
why is that so meaningful
peter the king will drop back to c1
uh maybe rook e7 to
e3 trying to collect some kingside pawns
yeah maybe but it's a little bit scary
it does feel a little bit scary suddenly
right yeah on the other hand thanks to
this
uh bishop on g6 you are hitting c2 so
whenever i take on a4 you might attack
my c2 pawn with
with the timely look f2 very very good
point
[Music]
there indeed all these possibilities but
it feels like uh
black is on the verge of collapse maybe
he can
escape by miracle okay
well magnus carlsen's fans have got
their
got a lump in their throat right now as
we are seeing the variation that we
looked at
and rook takes c5 the the the nice part
about that capture
you've been pointing out that the bishop
on g6 aims itself
against the pawn on c2 well now the rook
on c5
defends the pawn on c2 and white is
is ready is white ready for b4 here
and you know push them baby get those
pawns up the board
yeah very interesting idea instead of
trying to hunt the pawnee for done
it might simply cost too much time now
move like b4
forcing abc cb3 and then start pushing
the pawns as quickly as possible yeah
and hikaru did it b4 is on the board
again peter we should lower our voices
so that the players don't hear us
yeah well i'm not sure if that's the
that's the case
i think they have other things to worry
about right now but
uh look at this look look at hikaru go
he's saying uh uh go little one bring
his glory
to you can i go h5 can i create some
counterplay with h5 here yes and
uh h5 g5 does that open up the g7 i
don't know
um my goodness h5
trades and you're saying if you take
with the rook
um yeah crazy i know it's i think h5 is
is actually kind of necessary peter
whether it works or not
i don't think that you just want to
watch white go b4 b5
a6 and put your bishop on e4
i don't think that that's going to be
sufficient wait uh
the the the right way to hold the game i
think
well we are seeing rook okay
rook boy what
exactly is the idea yeah a6 played i
think
maybe b4 was possible ah magnus just
wants to
put the rook on a2 put the bishop on e4
and claim that you are not but
i can't believe that this works yeah
bishop a5 played
wow uh i thought we were going to see
rook c2
check as a prelude to the move rook a2
uh surprising for me that he didn't want
to put
white's king on a light square it would
have been very useful in my view
to have done that and now peter uh the
pawn
wow it got to a7 it got to a7
that to my mind says
game over b4 and rook c8
exactly i mean okay magnus wants to go
then h5 and uh
go desperately clear maybe that's why he
did not want to include
the check so that white's king is not
closer to g1
okay here we stop for a moment because
there's a lot to be said for rook
e8 tickling the bishop
yeah and it's on the board okay
so the idea is that with this move we've
also got rook
e6 check and it also depends just where
is that bishop going probably
it finds its way on the diagonal but
there is rookie six check
and picking up that f5 pawn if if we
like
we could also just take an and queen and
then
we've got a b-pawn that needs to be to
be pushed peter
yeah you can also take gf5 check yeah
black can't take it back yeah king f7
had to be played
right because king takes f5 would have
walked into rook f8 check
and you take the bishop yeah that's the
whole point you take the bishop you give
up the rook
and you make a girl all right so we have
seen king f7
queen takes takes g4
now the highly desirable beef
b4 oh the b5 threatens bishop before
check
was that all right so it's just over
it's over
that's the easy win that's an easy win
[Music]
yeah and magnus resigned yes
wow wow hikaru leads
with that first win that he had and to
take it into the armageddon
uh magnus needs to win we've got liftoff
let's get yas and peter in
thank you tanya and away they go peter
as
once again it's the english this time
not with g3 we saw before
uh one game in a previous set
i've lost count bishop b5 knight c3 had
been played
this time a totally different twist
queen c2 peter
yeah bishop b5 had been played and it
was in fact a game which also magnus had
to win it was maybe the very first set
uh when hikar won that and look at this
hicaru is
not surprised he blitzes out everything
he must have he must have prepared this
variation for this match
remarkable including this move f7 f5
so a2a3 the knight uh it hops back
um uh peter is something to be said for
bishop b5
now yeah absolutely i mean this is a
very similar to some i mean it's
basically a reverse posing right
exactly yeah but magnus one makes a
seven engine out of it yes so
d3 yeah with these three yeah so no more
powers and it's chavanningen
a big question it's always like there in
this validation vampire goes knight db5
and then comes back
we are seeing the same theme
the big question will white play knight
xd because white wants to go b4 you can
do it after trading on d5 but then
bishop
black gets a very strong bishop on d5 or
you go bishop d2 magnus chose knight
takes d5
i like this this it just feels so much
more direct b2b4 uh
threatening uh b5 and the e5 pawn is a
la tempo so b4 bishop f6 bishop b2
it feels like that's the
the the the right move order uh peter
b4 first of all uh step one uh peter
yeah b4 has to be played of course by y
this is the whole point black has to
slow it down with a6
and in this type of positions the
typical way is usually bishop b2 bishop
cca4 b5 or bishop cc queen b2
with reverse colors in the shavoning and
black is always in time to bring the
queen to
g3 here to g6 via queen e8
and then play bishop d6 and has strong
initiative on the king side
however here i do believe that temples
matter
very very much so i don't know who will
benefit
i mean it's clear that it invites favor
but if he can really claim an advantage
that's
that's another question exactly so we do
see bishop d6 i mean
forcibly reminded of the uh gary
kasparov versus this one i found a
non-match
vichy took the lead in that match
on the white side of the chevannigan
uh najdorf and with that bishop coming
to d6 that was what the
that was the game what reminded me of
that game
and as you prescribed the peter bishop
c3
intending queen b2 a4b5 uh
just hitting that pawn on e5 with
everything you got
yeah exactly i mean also making sure
that black was not in time for this
queen eight queen g6
yeah hikaru switches uh direction
he tries to play strategical fed bishop
g4 played he's fighting
for the d4 square and also by
signaling that aha no no my friend you
don't have free hand with queen b2
because then i might sacrifice the
exchange on f3
and get a very very strong attack so
white has to react to this
move with bishop after bishop g4 and if
you have to play a defensive move like
queen d3
it a little bit this balances white's
coordination but maybe you have to stop
bishop takes f3 rook takes f3
yeah i see that also uh peter just as
you've
mentioned as a real danger because again
uh magnus is in a force-winning position
it must win
must win game if it's a draw uh hikaru
nakamura will win the
magnus carlsen uh finals
so i do see uh perpetual checks or
repetitions
as being on the agenda i don't i mean
bishop c4 check followed by knight
moves might be okay if the knight could
move to
g5 but bishop c4 check king h8 knight d2
knight d4 i'm wondering why did i allow
the knight to drop in on d4
so whether you like it or not i think
you're right queen d3 looks like
it you just have to do it yeah but it
takes
too much time from magnus on the other
hand i believe magnus does
does it correctly i mean there is three
seconds increment
so after all time is not the decisive
if he can stabilize his position get the
balance
then uh things are hand queen a2 check
91 very interesting but
i don't know if it will work out well a
different approach he didn't want to
uh play to black's agenda so he's hoping
for once again a good knight versus bad
bishop he's dreaming
that black will play bishop e2 queenie
to knight d4
bishop d4 ed4 and then with the superb
blockading knight
knight to d3 uh magnus
would have every chances of equalizing
the game
so that was why uh hikaru declined
the opportunity to trade bishops he
played bishop d7
but isn't it time to now bring the
knight on e1 back into play peter
yes definitely white wants to bring it
back the question is
where to bring it back i mean do you
want some knight c to knight e3
which looks ideal but then black will
have this knight before idea
and after the exchange on d4
the knight would be misplaced
magnus put the knight on dc basically
indicating that
now cover any kind of knight d force
without knight d4 you don't really have
an attack going
and i just slowly want to stabilize my
position and
after all let's not forget black has a
weak pawn on e5
black's spawn structure is worse so he
has to try to create dynamic uni
compensation for the damaged pawn
structure queen h4 played
and by the way don't forget that in this
hyper aggressive match
f2 f4 could have been a potential
issue when the queen was on f6 so
hikaru uh sidestepped the fact that his
uh his e5 pawn was in a bit of a pin
queen h4
pretty picking up a tempo against e4
rookie eight
and wow it's
this this game feels really
tense peter i uh this is fantastic
it's just been a great pleasure to call
the action with you
and tanya but wow
the the players keep delivering uh peter
yeah absolutely i mean i'm also very
very nervous i mean i don't know why i'm
so nervous i simply feel with the
fear with the players i mean whoever
will lose i will really feel very sorry
for him
so yeah i'm very very tense now right
now rooting for magnus maybe to come
back
but uh okay hikaru also deserves
everything what he has done in this
match so
yeah let's just enjoy the show yeah
they're going toe-to-toe queen d2
there's a the there's a pause here
because bishop d3 tickling the rook
just suggesting to the rook that it
shouldn't be on the open d
file uh is one idea another idea is to
just plant the bishop on c4
uh another idea is to potentially double
the rooks on the f file
now that the f3 pawn is a little bit
weakened and bishop b3 uh
my let's say uh knee-jerk move was uh
hikaru's choice
rook c1 and peter the clocks
well uh magnus is uh magnus
i want to say significantly behind one
minute is huge
as we know in armageddon peter yeah well
it's even
more than a minute already on the other
hand his position is stable so he might
be able to make
very natural moves yeah hikaru tries to
use that minute
by messing things up with the a5
whoa whoa there's a hanging bishop on b3
knight e5 95b oh but then there's bishop
d4 and there's a rook on f2
sorry sorry peter i just thought there
was a hanging pawn
uh this one it doesn't work but can he
play b5
uh peter and then take on e5 because
this is saying
oh there's knight d4 oh geez
peter it's it's it's it's super sharp
yeah it's super sharp now magnus played
the move knight c5 which i
don't like at all black can take on c5
play a4 get the knight to d4
no hikaru takes a before that's a that's
a big surprise
okay anyway after bishop takes e5 of
course why takes queen takes c5 pardon
me
the key idea from from white white has
to
trade the queens and this case in the
end game the pawn on e5
uh might be might be weak precisely
that's the imbalance that uh
magnus is striving to create
that uh the two bishops in an ending and
the pawn on e5
weakness uh one minute to two minutes
and the the tension keeps ratcheting it
ratcheting
up uh i still i still fed like
this option of playing a5 a4 in
eventually
was a very important resource for black
so i'm intuitively i'm not liking this
exchange on b4 but
in blitz it's so natural that okay let
me play instantly a b a b then i take on
c5
but it might have been a slight
inaccuracy all right and we have seen
the trade of queens uh knight jumps to
d4 king g2
a psychological moment as uh
as magnus invites of bishops of opposite
color
he's banking on the fact that he will
have the dark square bishop
and thanks to the pressure eventually
against the pawn on g7
he'll be superior is he right peter
well i mean now he goes for the pawn
grab i felt like maybe
it's more magnus style just to defend
with luke f2
force that force that passive position
with black with after rookie 8 and try
to play maybe g4 h for king gc and
just to play that position but maybe
magnus magnus fed like he can
he can just grab the pawn and but bishop
a for bishop to
i know bishop a4 he takes look b7 or
what uh there was a problem with bishop
d1
in the position after rook f2
wasn't so clear uh ah yes very nice
point yeah
then i might be even forced to give the
exchange right
exactly but you're right bishop c6
rook takes rook takes bishop takes e4
oh my goodness what's going on this oh
no
bishop c6 bishop g7 i apologize i
don't want to fall into a a double
attack tactic
uh peter yeah did maybe hikaru miss it
because the point was that
actually the bishop was not hanging on
bc thanks to the look on f3 so there was
no other reason that black had to move
this rook but
okay the tension now he carries below
one minute
magnus is ahead on the clock wow what is
happening here
well rook takes b7 it looks like it's
just
over after c5 c6
and i gotta think that that is
a winning position for white he's done
it oh my god
winning on demand this would
runs be bishop d6 now right
sorry sorry i mean rookie 7 bishop d6 is
a
winning trick oh that's a beauty please
show that to our audience
as that is a marvelous little tactic
rookie 7 bishop
d6 uh skewering a rook
and the pawn is pinned so that would win
in exchange
hence the move h5 and
magnus uh to play
and peter the pawn on c7 sure looks
tempting what's wrong with grabbing the
pawn
yeah but how do you uh take it because
if you shoot with the rook then i have
rook see it at the end
bishop takes c7 bishop takes seven is my
move uh
peter aha bishop takes c7 yeah and no
tricks
right well rook c8 then i go back with
my bishop bishop f4
and uh all the rooks are hanging but
that's an extra pawn
and he has done it and now
we've see okay now there's one trick in
the position
for hikaru and that is bishop f4 double
question mark
bishop c6 with the swish and zug bishop
e4
and that would clinch the
tournament victory the tour victory for
for ikaru but don't go bishop f4 go
bishop
d6 so that you can tickle the rook
on f8 and that should win for magnus
uh uh peter yeah but magnus down to nine
seconds on the clock
nine seconds old position should be
winning but
okay let's not forget about the clock
then nine
seconds did the world champion
oh there's one rocket for him it doesn't
matter now yeah
take the rust over take the rook on f2
and promote the pawn to a queen
that would have been an easy win he's
played rook c eight
and oh it's over it's over yeah magnus
bonds back
tied again